we're here with wesley so two in a row
wesley now with the black pieces feeling
good yeah definitely uh well first
thanks for having me here aleandra and
good to see you good to see you as well
yeah yeah i'm very happy i mean i played
like all berlin
during my black games which is a bit
boring but
it's uh what i know the best and it's
worked out well i mean ivan sark is a
very strong local player his rating is
2680
so he's very well booked up so i thought
i figured instead of going for a riskier
opening such as the sicilian i thought
just play one e45 and see what happens
and he's played this line before i did
some minor preparations beforehand but i
think i equalized relatively well and he
maybe he could have simplified to a draw
early in the opening but he made some
mistakes like we need to i thought it
was a slight mistake and gave me some
chances but uh i also made some mistakes
but the end game was crazy let's talk a
little bit about what you said some
boring opening with the brilliant h65
this position that we have on the board
how did you assess it during the game
well i figured i have some slight
chances main reason because this king is
stuck
and i'm just in time to stop in three
spawns but at the same time i only had
less than a minute on the clock which
was a bit worrying i mean i could have
made the draw but figured i just
yeah i think i'm just in time to stop
the pawns and why just be very accurate
to make it apparently don't be there
says knight g8 check here forces the
draw
did you feel that you had a win at some
point like when were you sure that this
was in your pocket
uh well when i grabbed his pawns
when i grabbed both queenside pawns so
when i played like uh when i played
roguely one uh i kind of controlled his
pawns and he tried making it stuck so
he's gonna run up move sooner or later
uh that was a lot of zoo zone it's a
beautiful suzong game thank you yeah i
figured
uh from afar i thought this was going to
be a win so i was quite happy yeah so
when i played king b7 i thought that
it's very difficult for white to defend
i mean
i guess the main plan here is to bring
the king the black king to f2 and then
create some swan and uh probably also
here like i could play h4 here at some
point like i think yeah right there
getting h4
but okay h4 wins alpha
but in any case uh i mean we made some a
few mistakes in the game which is quite
expected in the rapid game it sounded
like excellent quality from both players
especially yours let's take a look at
what's going on in the last game just so
that we don't lose our
our focus tell us about your thoughts
about this engine right now
yeah i was strong with bethel in before
and
a few months back we figured there was
absolutely no way for black to make
progress
but now it seems jordan is making some
progress and he just made one more pawn
move man so so you got to reset the
counter right
another 45 more moves so why didn't he
take out if he takes rook d7 what if it
takes if he takes here and then it gets
rook somewhere uh actually the
television says it's a draw in this
position after king takes h2 he could
have taken the pawn oh and then he
played bishop g there okay okay and the
game is over as rook p3 rook takes b3 a
beautiful little stalemate trick there
at the end to finish this one a draw
between maxima sherlock and yordevan
forest yes
wesley got to ask you we had big news
yesterday what were your feelings as a
player that's participating in the
candidate cycle yeah definitely shocking
i mean i thought the
magnus was still a big favorite like uh
a lot of told me that maybe
you know magnus just wants to go out and
win but he's clearly by far my opinion
the strongest player so it's very
shocking i mean i can understand that
he's played a lot of world championship
matches already
and he doesn't want to play i guess 14
classical games and there's a lot of
training involved and
maybe he wants to do other things
uh but
yeah definitely shocking at the same
time i
feel this will give other players more
chances and more initiatives so player
like you
yeah yeah i mean
i think uh mike has been number one for
11 years so it's
quite depressing
for other players so now that he won't
be part of the world championship cycle
then it's a big five relief but
it's definitely interesting because he's
very young and
he's
got a lot of gas left on his tank but
we'll we'll see what happens uh he's
here
absolutely well wesley will let you go
because we're a few minutes away from
the round thank you for being with us
let's go back to the studio and get
ready for round number two of the day
thank you alejandro thank you wesley
we'll go to our standings
miro after
round four is completed
and here they are